[Music]
well good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight this is our last day in
Kyoto Japan we're heading in as we
interview with the president after the
show won't bring you the whole thing on
Monday we've been following closely
what's happening back in the homeland in
the u.s. last night of course marked the
second straight Democratic primary
debate a lot of what passes for heavy
hitters on the Left were in attendance
Joe Biden pobud ajudge Kamala Harris
Bernie Sanders on the question of
immigration at least they all seemed in
total agreement sorry for the tape mix
up there that was the party's youth wing
and Tifa making pretty much the same
point but watch father Pete Buddha judge
and this is the right tape and Buddha
judge keep in mind is not only a mayor
and a presidential candidate but he's a
self-described moral leader like Mahatma
Ghandi or Jackson Browne watch him
explain it's just wrong morally wrong to
maintain international borders that
criminalization that is the basis for
family separation you do away with that
it's no longer possible of course it
wouldn't be possible anyway in my
presidency because it is dead wrong got
that sneaking into someone else's
country can never be a crime doesn't
matter if you're a Chinese spy an ms-13
gang member a drug mule with 20 kilos of
heroin on your back doesn't matter if
you're a human trafficker with a stable
of child prostitutes you are welcome
here we won't judge you in fact we will
gladly pay for your comprehensive
medical care whatever it takes that's
how much we hate ourselves watch where's
your hand if covered if your government
plan would provide coverage for
undocumented immigrants got that mr. and
mrs. American you may be going broke
trying to pay for your own family's
health care and many of you are by the
way but now you get to pay for free
health care for the rest of the whole
world anyone
ignores our laws in sneaks in you owe
them benefits the second they get here
got that racist if you don't like it
tough the Democratic Party plans to
disarm you so you're powerless much
congressman Eric's wawel promised to
seize every semi-automatic rifle in this
country I'm the only candidate on this
stage calling for a ban and buyback of
every single assault weapon in America
has an actual member of Congress but
wait doesn't the Constitution and allows
people our lawyer so ask them this
doesn't the Constitution guarantee your
right to keep and bear arms well yes the
document says that but once Bernie
Sanders gets finished moving
conservatives off the Supreme Court the
left can do whatever it wants watch him
explain I do not believe in packing the
court
we got a terrible fight for majority
conservative court right now but I do
believe that constitutionally we have
the power to rotate judges to other
courts and that brings in new blood into
the Supreme Court Bernie Sanders talking
about new blood it's also great but keep
in mind that's not court packing not
even close
its court rotating and that means
getting rid of judges that Bernie
Sanders doesn't like and installing
judges who agree with Bernie Sanders
that's totally different the other
candidate seemed on board with that or
any case they were too busy attacking
Joe Biden to notice what the old guy
from Vermont was saying there was a lot
to hit Biden on Biden sex his skin color
his sexual orientation they're all sins
against the religion of woke nests Plus
as congressman Eric's wawel helpfully
pointed out Joe Biden is really really
old I was six years old when a
presidential candidate came to the
California Democratic convention and
said it's time to pass the torch to a
new generation of Americans that
candidate was then-senator Joe Biden Joe
Biden was right when he said it was time
to pass the torch to a new generation of
Americans 32 years ago
is still right today if we're going to
solve the issues of automation
satori we're gonna solve the issues of
climate chaos pass the torch got that
old man Joe Biden is a musty antique who
ought to be eating soft food in Florida
somewhere and you know what else he's a
racist a bitter elderly bigot he's
probably sitting in his den right now
watching Birth of a Nation drinking
Schlitz camel eye Harris made that clear
she started out by saying that Joe Biden
is not a racist meaning of course he's
definitely a racist I'm gonna now direct
this at Vice President Biden I do not
believe you are a racist but you also
worked with them to oppose busing and
you know there was a little girl in
California who was part of the second
class to integrate her public schools
and she was bused to school every day
and that little girl was me everything
about that was fake it's hard to imagine
more disingenuous paragraph where to
begin
I mean kamla harris implies that
california schools were segregated in
the 1970s they were not some of us were
there at the time Harris herself was not
a civil rights hero her father was
literally a Stanford economics professor
she went to high school in Montreal
Canada she was a child of privilege if
there ever was one
as for forced busing it's amazing that
anybody a particularly any Democrat
would defend it busing didn't work it
was an abject failure guess who hated it
black families it took black kids out of
their neighborhoods and it patronized
them didn't raise anybody's scores in
the end busing didn't work honest people
on the Left admit that Brookings
admitted that the only people who liked
busing then and now are rich liberals
the ones totally insulated from the
effects of their failed and stupid
social policy everyone else in this
country 90% of Americans according to
Gallup polling at the height of busing
and that's 90 percent of both black and
white Americans thought busing was awful
so good call Democrats run on that more
busing Joe Biden's a racist here's our
nominee Kamla Harris listen to her
explain why
she's a very good person and you're
morally flawed good call that'll
definitely work just like it did with
Hillary Clinton last time morons